the White House is gearing up for its
next big battle in Congress immigration
reform a group of Republican and
Democratic lawmakers will discuss it
with President Trump this morning they
are trying to work out differences on
protecting so-called dreamers and
building a wall along the Mexican border
immigration is likely to be a key issue
and talks to avoid a government shutdown
next Friday Margaret Brennan is at the
White House Margaret good morning to you
good morning while the White House has
11 days to reach a budget agreement with
Democrats or at least come up with a
short-term plan to fund the government
and avoid that shutdown on January 19th
a long-term deal may depend on striking
a bipartisan immigration agreement now
that may be an uphill battle because
Republicans are saying here that
Democrats are holding out for that deal
on daca that's the Obama era program
that shields undocumented immigrants who
came to this country as children from
now being deported over the weekend the
president said he'd only do that if
Democrats support his campaign pledge to
build a border wall now he says he still
believes Mexico will ultimately pay for
the wall but in the meantime he's asking
Congress for 18 billion dollars to fund
it along with related border security
provisions yesterday in Tennessee mr.
Trump also pledged to end a visa lottery
system and shut down a program that
allows immigrants to bring along their
family members today vice president Mike
Pence will join the president in that
bipartisan meeting with Senate leaders
to try to reach some kind of
breakthrough Jeff Margaret thank you
very much